نعم اهلا بك طاهره واهلا بالمشاهدين قناه
العربيه طبعا هذه الطائره هي الطائره
الثانيه التي الان تتجه او تستعد
لتحميل الحاويات الاخيره وهي
مكونه من مواد غذائيه واغاثيه ومستلزمات
طبيه طائره اذا طائره شحن السعوديه
تحمل اكثر من 100 طن من المستلزمات الطبيه
والمواد الغذائيه والاغاثيه وهي مقدمه من
مركز الملك سلمان لغاته والاعمال
الانسانيه بعد توجيه العاهل السعودي الملك
سلمان وولي عهدي طبعا هذه الطائره سبقتها
ايضا طائره اخرى وكانت تحمل قرابه التسعين
طن من المواد الغذائيه والاغاثيه اجمالي
ما سوف تقدمه حتى هذه اللحظه او ما سوف
يصل الى مطار اضنه في تركيا قرابه ال270
طن هناك طائره ايضا ايضا تجهز ولكن سوف
تغادر
في مسائي هذا اليوم اضافه الى هذه المواد
الغذائيه والمستلزمات الطبيه هناك طائره
اخرى ثالثه ولكن في الجهه الاخرى وهي
محمله باليات ومعدات حديثه ومتطوره ومقدمه
من مديريه الدفاع المدني وايضا بعد ساعه
سوف تغادر طائره رابعه تحمل ما يقارب
المئه شخص من الطواقم المهيئه والمخصصه في
فرق الانقاذ والكوارث وحاصلون على اعلى
الرخص الدوليه وهم من ضمن الفرق
التابعه لي او منسوبين مديريه الدفاع
المدني وسوف يغادرونا قرابه الساعه
الثالثه والنصف من صباح هذا اليوم اي بعد
ساعه تقريبا ولكن من المطار الاخر وتابع
لمطار الملك خالد الدولي من الصلاه
الخاصه طبعا ما زلنا نواكب او ما زالت
العربيه تواكب عمليات المساعدات وايضا
الشحنه المساعدات المقدمه من السعوديه الى
مطار اضنه لا ننسى ان كانت هناك طائره
ايضا اولى وصلت في ساعات الصباح الاولى
وايضا كانت تحمل ايضا من من فرق الاطباء
وايضا
الممثلين مركز الملك سلمان الذين سوف
يقفون على الاحتياجات الملحه لمثل هذه
الكوارث لا ننسى ايضا ان هناك فريق طبي
ايضا من مديريه الدفاع المدني وكذلك فنيين
ومهندسين سوف يغادرون في رحله اخرى خلال
الساعات النهار القادمه برفقه او سوف
يرافقون ايضا الطواقم البالغ عددهم 100
شخص ما زلنا ان نواكب عمليه
مغادره هذه الحاويات هناك نتحدث عن 32
حاويه فقط في طائره الشحن السعوديه
تحمل الان على هذه الطائره لا ننسى ايضا
ان هناك ايضا ما يزيد عن 50 او 60 طن من
المستلزمات الطبيه مقدما من مركز الملك
سلمان وهذه المستلزمات الطبيه هي
للاحتياجات الخاصه بمثل هذه الكوارث او ما
يحتاجها المتضررين في مثل هذه الكوارث
اضافه الى تقنيات ومعدات تزيل الاعمال
الخرسانيه او الركام
لدى المتضررين جراء هذا الزلزال
تبقى معنا واذا بالامكان انه